غضب شعبي من النظام ترى كما لاكثر من 40
عاما في ايران انفجرت حمامه في الستين
يوما الماضيه في مظاهرات جلد شوارع المدن
الايرانيه لتكون الاطول والاكثر استمراريه
منذ عقود
احتجاجات يوميه
على يد الامن الايراني تزداد حده خطابها
يوما بعد يوم بمطالب اسقاط النظام
احرق فيها المتظاهرون صور رموز ذلك النظام
وقبضته الحديديه كصور مرشدي ايران
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات بدات على نطاق ضيق وفي ظل خوف من
المقابل الا ان دائره التعبير اتسعت الى
معظم مدن ايران وتنوعت اشكال التظاهر ولم
تقتصر على التجمل والشعارات ليلا ونهارا
في الشوارع والمدارس والجامعات بل تجسد
الرفض والغضب في الاضرابات العامه واغلاق
المحلات والحملات الاعلاميه على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وتاليف اغان عن انتفاضه
افاقتها جدائل نساء وفتيات ايران جماعه
الفنانين واللاعبين والسينمائيين رايت
ويكون فراخ زيدان
اكثر من مره يرفض اللاعبون في المنتخبات
الايرانيه ترديد النشيد يعني كما حدث مع
منتخب كره القدم الشاطئيه والذي فاز
بالبطوله لتعتقلهم قوات الباسيج فور
وصولهم الى طهران مع اتساع اساليب
المتظاهرين بقي النظام الايراني على
اسلوبه الاوحد منذ اليوم الاول قمع
للمتظاهرين وتفريق بالقوه والعنف
واعتقالات بالجمله ولم يتوقف عندما ساء
ميني بل كرر ماساتها مع متظاهرات مراهقات
وباتت عقوبه الاعدام سلاحا يلوح به النظام
في سبيل يمثل الرعب في صدور المتظاهرين
علهم يتراجعون الى عمر العربيه